The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: This
is my second lecture
on the example, the model
of graphs and networks.
Really perfect, beautiful
model for the whole framework.
And important in itself.
So, I guess a major thing
that I still have to do
is discuss A transpose.
See how A transpose
just naturally appears
in the balance law.
Kirchhoff's current
law, KCL, is just
like a model for
balance equations.
By balance I mean, in
equals out, essentially.
Flow in equals flow
out because we're
talking about steady state.
So in each node, at
node three, for example,
I have three edges.
So the law, Kirchhoff's
current law at that point
is going to tell me that the
flow w_2 plus w_3 minus w_5
would be zero if there's
no current source,
or if I'm feeding current
into there, some current f_3,
then it would match f_3.
So maybe having just
said those words,
let me just say, w_2,
I'll say it again,
w_2 plus w_3 minus
w_5, and I'm hoping
that I'll find that in
the third column here.
And I do.
Because I'm thinking,
and we'll write it down,
I'm thinking to
take a transpose,
so it'll be the
third row, and here I
see the w_2, w_3
and minus w_5 that
will show up in the
third equation there,
the in equals out at node three.
Well I'll write that
down, because it's-- So,
two or three jobs for today.
And then Monday I plan to
spend a part of the lecture
and all of the review
session in review,
it's a great chance to go
back to the things we've done
and collect them, assemble
them, organize them and see them
again.
So that's my goal for
both sessions on Monday.
And questions, then,
about every aspect.
So, before I get to A
transpose, this part
I had written down last time,
but there's a little more
to say.
And what I was saying
and want to continue with
is the source terms.
I put in this b but I didn't
draw anything on the network.
So let me draw what
these b's represent.
So this second, lower, row
is about edge equations,
edge variables.
So those batteries
b are on the edges.
And there will be,
b has length five.
There are five edges.
This is a vector of length
five, this matrix, A,
you remember was five by four.
It produced from four
inputs, from four potentials
at the four nodes, A produces
Au, five potential differences.
So those are the
differences in potentials.
But then also there
can be source terms
from batteries in the
edges, and the minus sign
is there because I'm
talking about voltage drops.
So when I say
differences I'm really
speaking about voltage drops.
Because that's the
way current flows.
OK, this is the
moment that I hate.
Putting the batteries in.
I think you draw a battery
with a long and a short?
Is that right?
And then you put a
plus and a minus?
Well, can I just say, life
is too short to get those,
to get this sign right.
You may say when my
car battery stalls
how do I, because it's
important at that moment, right?
When you start it
up you're supposed
to put the right battery, the
right lead on the positive
and the right on the negative,
or your blow yourself up.
OK.
So what's my solution?
Because I literally refuse
to deal with these signs.
So my solution is call AAA.
OK, they're paid to
blow themselves up.
They can do it.
But so this is serious
now, I don't want
to be asked about these signs.
And I forgive you for
messing up the signs.
So possibly that's plus,
possibly minus, I don't know.
But there's a battery
in there of length b_1,
of voltage-- A nine-volt
battery, b_1 would be nine.
And depending how it
was placed in there,
the b here would be a
plus nine or a minus nine
in the first component.
And then if I had
another battery here,
a b that's on edge four,
there would be a battery b_4,
and that would show
up there in Ohm's law.
Because Ohm's law will
look at the difference
in these potentials,
but then it'll also
account for the battery, right?
The voltage that comes from
the battery, and somehow
combining the Au, which is
the difference in these guys,
with the b_4, I'll know
what is the voltage drop
across the resistor.
And that's what
Ohm's law applies to.
Ohm's law says the voltage
drop across the resistor
times the conductance, so this
is Ohm's law, that on that edge
the voltage drop across the
resistor times the conductance
gives the current.
So that's the physical law.
Is that OK?
For batteries.
Now a comment on
current sources.
So what's with current sources?
How would I draw those?
Well, very often maybe I
might draw a current going
into node one, so that would be
in f_1 that goes into node one
and maybe comes out at ground.
So that would be a typical f.
That if I imposed
a current source,
if I sent a current
source through there
it would go down and
come out at ground,
and our question is what are
the currents in the five edges?
What are the potentials
at the four nodes?
Well, I'm making
this one ground.
So I'm grounding
this one to be u_4=0.
And you remember
of course why I had
to do that, because this matrix
A transpose A, as it stands
is-- What's the matter with
A transpose A as it stands?
It's singular, right?
And as I, looking ahead,
just a small comment,
that this will have
exactly the same thing
in so many other applications
in big, finite element codes,
you produce a stiffness matrix
that's initially singular.
And then you impose the
boundary conditions.
That's the efficient
way to do it,
is create the matrix
first, that's the big job,
then impose the
boundary conditions,
that's the small but
occasionally tricky part.
Now I indicated
what happened here.
When u_4 was zero, that
means that A times u, the u_4
there, the zero is multiplying
this, is not unknown any more.
It's known.
And so that column is not
really any more needed in A.
Because u_4 is gone from my
list of unknown potentials.
Now, at the same time, when I
went over to A transpose A--
I'm making this
comment because there
were several good
questions about it.
I claim that also,
that row, coming,
which of course comes from
the fourth row of A transpose.
The fourth column of A is
gone, so the fourth row
of A transpose should be gone.
And we might just think
why's that, what's going on?
Of course, it produces
exactly what we want.
It leaves us with a
three by three matrix
that's not singular any more.
I've removed that [1, 1, 1, 1]
from the null space by fixing
a potential.
Grounding a node,
and the problem
becomes just what we want.
And I'll write
down the equations
when I get the Kirchhoff current
law to complete the loop.
Now, what's going on?
Let me remove this
current source,
just so we focus on what
I'm speaking about now.
On this type of
boundary condition,
this is like fixing
a support, right?
It's like fixing a support
in our spring mass problem.
Can I squeeze in a little
spring mass problem,
so I have a spring, and then
I'm fixing this displacement,
u_4 to be zero.
Now, I want to try
to think through what
happens in a balance
equation, A transpose w,
let me make it A
transpose w equal f,
because that's the case with
right hand side allowed.
And now what happens
when I fix this,
I'm asking you to think back
about force balance, which
we certainly saw was an A
transpose w equal f business.
And then parallel will be the
current balance, at that node.
OK, so what was the
deal on force balance?
A transpose with
this fixed in here.
What was the thing with A
transpose that that fixed in?
We did not write the
equation A transpose w equal
f at this point.
We did not write the force
balance equation at that point.
When I fixed u_4, in this case
it was the displacement so I'm
fixing it at zero
displacement, I
didn't have a force balance
in the A transpose part
at this node.
Now, you could say why?
Because of course
forces have to balance.
But what's going on?
What's really happening here
is I don't have to write out,
I don't have to-- the
displacement here is known.
It's not unknown.
And let me say it in a sentence.
Force balance does hold
because the support
supplies whatever force it takes
to balance the internal forces.
So, in other words, let me say
that again, the force balance
will hold and it will
tell me, after I've
solved the rest of the
problem, it'll tell me
what the support has to supply,
how much force the support is
actually supplying.
It's a reaction force,
it would be called.
So a reaction force is
whatever the support has
to do to fix that displacement.
And so I solved
the fixed problems
for all the other displacements
and all the spring forces.
And then I could
come back at the end
and say OK, what was the force
in that spring and therefore
how much is that support,
what's the force being supplied
by that support.
See what I'm saying?
That the force balance at
this node comes afterwards.
That equation is like knocking
that one out of this problem.
It would be the same here,
I fix the potential at zero.
I fix ground at zero.
Current flows.
Maybe some, maybe I might
fix that potential at one.
I fix that potential at zero.
Current flows.
OK.
Ta-da, I find out, I
compute what they are,
and this row and
column will be gone.
Find out what they are.
At this node, what's happened?
What's happening to the
balance of currents?
Does this current have
to balance that current
at the ground?
No.
The ground, whatever
current comes here
plus whatever current comes
here, goes into ground.
Do you see the point?
Kirchhoff's current
law, the balance
of currents that in
equals out, is true
but it's not an
equation I have to solve
in finding the
currents, it's something
I can discover at the end.
I can say OK, how much
current flowed from ground?
And similarly up here.
If I fix u_1 to be
zero, then you, no, I
don't want to fix it to be
zero too, that would be a way
to make very little happen.
Let me fix u_1 to
be one, so this is
a standard important problem.
It's like what's the
resistance in the net-- what's
the net system resistance?
If I fix this at one fix this
at zero, some current will flow,
it'll come out here.
And that'll be the
current going into here.
Somehow there'll be a balance
there, and a balance there.
But it's found later.
Just the way the force in
the support is found later.
OK, that takes a
little thinking.
I just wanted to, because I had
blithely knocked this row out.
And you could do
it on the basis,
well if you knock
out this column of A
then you're knocking out
the row of A transpose,
and therefore A transpose
A will be three by three.
And it'll go down to two by
two if I fix that potential.
And if I don't fix it at
zero, if I fix it at one
then something will move
to the right hand side.
OK. that's that point I
hope at least discussed.
So now we have the
whole pattern here.
Except that I really have still
to justify the fact that it
truly is A transpose, the
transpose of that matrix,
that comes into
Kirchhoff's current law.
I guess in the first
minute of the lecture I
looked at that particular node.
Let's look at all the nodes.
Let me look at A
transpose w equals zero.
OK.
So I'll copy a transpose
because I truly
believe that Kirchhoff
would want me to do it.
OK, so that becomes a row, that
becomes the next row, of course
I see three guys
going into node one,
then the one that
I looked at before.
That's the three edges, node
three, and then the last one.
Let's keep the last
one in for now.
And because if I didn't fix
that I'd have that last one.
There we go, so that multiplies,
what does that multiply now
in Kirchhoff's current law?
Multiplies w, so currents.
So here the currents, one,
two, three, four and five.
All I'm doing now is
just, like, convincing you
that it really is a
transpose, that if I look at,
let me pick that
node now, if I look
at that node I see
edge one coming in,
I see edge three going out,
I see edge four going out
and when I look at
that second node,
I look here at the second
row, I see edge one coming in,
edge three and edge
four going out,
multiplying those currents,
and that will give,
that current balance
there gives that zero.
Right?
That current balance
at node two gives that
zero in the right hand side.
And then, of course,
other zeroes are here too.
This is minus w_1, minus
w_2, so I have a zero.
This is with no current sources.
OK.
And this one, of course.
I guess I'm hoping that you
say yes, the A transpose really
was the right matrix to express
in equals out, Kirchhoff's
current law.
OK.
Of course, by now you're
probably getting blasé.
You expect it to be A transpose,
you don't need any convincing.
But it's kind of good to
see each time because it's
like, well, it's not a miracle.
But it's like a miracle.
It's as good as a miracle.
Because to get A
transpose is just
what makes everything right.
Now, here's a question.
This is a question
worth thinking about.
What are the solutions?
If I only look at this
piece of the framework,
if I just look at Kirchhoff's
current law, it's telling me,
and I have zero current sources.
Well let's take
that, let me take
just this piece of the
whole framework and ask you,
how many vectors w,
how many solutions?
Are there any solutions?
Well, of course, there's
always the zero solution.
But I always ask you, what
are the solutions when
zero is on the right hand side?
So, what are the w's that
solve Kirchhoff's current law.
Now that's a new question.
We haven't asked that before.
What we asked before was
the question Au, Au=0,
remember it was then A.
This five by four matrix,
u had four components.
Just remind me, and I'm
putting that column back in,
so this is still here.
In the un-reduced,
un-grounded case.
Well, just so we get
started, remind me
what the solutions u were for
Au equals zero. [1, 1, 1, 1].
Or any multiple of it.
A whole line of vectors.
[c, c, c, c], any constant c.
OK, so this had, there
were four columns.
But only three were independent.
OK.
Now, now I've made
them into rows.
And I made the
rows into columns.
So now I have five columns.
What I'm leading to is, I
want to count in advance
how many w's I should be looking
for, and then look for them.
OK, so the first question is
how many different solutions w.
First of all, are
there some solutions?
Is there is a solution w,
other than zero of course,
to this system?
Well, as we said
last time, we've
only got four equations here.
We've got five unknowns.
Of course there's at
least one solution.
Four equations, five unknowns,
I can do elimination,
whatever systematic
procedure you want me to do.
In the end, I'm going
to find a solution.
Now, I might find
more solutions.
So that's the question.
So what's the, now this is the
key fact of linear algebra.
Which is, it just tells us
the numbers of everything.
So this told us that there
were three independent columns.
Of A. Now, for that key
theorem, which tells me that,
how many independent
rows of A are there?
Three.
That number is equal.
I just want to say that's
a pretty remarkable fact.
If I have a 50 by 80 matrix
and that 50 by 80 matrix
has 17 independent columns,
then this great fact
tells me that there are
17 independent rows.
And if those 50 times 80,
4,000 numbers are random,
boy, you can't look at
it and see what are they.
Independent rows.
But if you know there are
17 independent columns then
there are 17 independent rows.
So, what does that mean here?
That means that out
of the five columns
of A transpose, which were rows
of A, three are independent.
So just tell me, how many
solutions I'm looking for.
Before I look for them.
So the number of-- The
number of independent w's,
independent solutions
will be what?
What's your guess?
Two!
Two is the right guess.
Two, because I have
altogether five unknowns,
I subtract three equations
that are really there,
I have three real
equations there
even though it looks like four.
And I get two.
So that general
picture is n-- Oh, I'm
sorry it's actually m because
I'm doing the transpose here.
So it's m w's minus r, the rank.
So that's m is five,
the rank is three
and this counts the number
of independent solutions.
So it's a nice, it
couldn't be better.
It's a fundamental count of
how many solutions are there.
You're really taking the
number of unknowns, five,
and you're subtracting
the number of equations
that are really there,
three, and that leaves you
with two solutions which we
will have to find in a minute.
Can you say why there's really
only three equations there?
Why do I say that that
fourth equation is not
contributing anything new?
I believe that that fourth
equation is a consequence
of the first three.
And, therefore, if it's
there or if it's not there,
it's not telling me
anything new about in=out.
In other words, if I
have a closed system,
closed because it's
zero on the right side,
if I have a closed system and
I have in=out at those three
nodes, then I'll automatically
have in=out at the fourth node,
because the total in is zero.
And the total out is zero.
So if I'm right at three I'll
be right at the fourth one.
And now just tell
me with the numbers,
how would I get this equation
w_4+w_5=0 from the first three?
Well, it's probably
the same way that I
got that column,
that that column was
connected to those columns.
What do I do?
Add them.
If you add that equation to
that equation to that equation,
add those three
equations, what happens?
the w_1's cancel, the w_2's
cancel, the w_3's cancel,
this says there's a
minus w_4 and a minus w_5
that adds to zero plus
zero plus zero, minus w_4,
minus w_5 equalling zero
is the same as plus w_4
plus w_5 equals zero.
The four equations add
to zero equals zero.
That's what the
central thing is.
The four equations add
to zero equals zero just
the way the four columns up
here added to the zero column.
OK.
So we got the count.
Now, this is the
interesting part, always.
What are the solutions?
What are the actual w's?
OK.
You could say, wait
a minute, you're
asking me to solve four
equations and five unknowns,
and just say what the answer is.
Well, normally that's
not reasonable.
But here we can get
help from the graph.
Let me give you an idea here.
So what are we looking for
on the graph, that solves it?
We're looking for
a bunch of currents
that balance themselves.
Right?
We've got zero on
the right hand side.
So we're not getting
any help from outside.
How could you send
current in this loop
in a way that would
satisfy Kirchhoff.
He'd be happy.
The balance law would be true.
OK. b-- I'm just
looking at currents.
Current w_1, w_2, w_3.
Is there any
combination of w_1, w_2,
w_3 that would balance itself,
that would make Kirchhoff OK?
Well, here's the idea.
Send that current around a loop.
Loop currents are solutions
to Kirchhoff's balance law.
If I send an amp on
that edge, on that edge
and backward on
that edge, right?
It's around a loop at every
node, it's totally OK.
So I believe that a
particular solution will
be for these things to be,
let's see what did I say? w_1,
I'll send one around. w_3 will
be a one. w_2 was backwards,
it wasn't traveling on w_4.
I think that's a solution.
That loop current
gives me a solution so
let me call this solution,
that's the first solution.
And if we do these
multiplications, of course
it's going to come out right.
OK, so that's
solution number one.
A w that works.
OK, with that hint, tell
me a second w that works.
In fact, since
there are only two,
you'll be giving me
the rest of the answer.
So that was a loop current
that went around that loop.
Tell me another one.
Well, we're a big class
but everybody's seen it.
How about around that loop?
So that would be
another thing and it's
pretty clearly not
the same as this one.
So I'm really truly finding
two independent solutions.
And what is that
second solution?
Let me maybe just
put it in here.
And they're both giving
me [0,  0, 0, 0].
And now, what is this number two
solution, the loop number two?
One and two are
not involved now.
Number three, see I'm usually
sending it counterclockwise,
that's the sort of convention.
But you know, of
course you just have
to follow some convention in
connection with the arrows.
So that would go backwards
on three, I think.
Forwards on four, and
backwards on five.
So that would be
solution number two.
OK.
Now, tell me what all
the solutions are.
I found two particular
solutions, two particular loop
currents, particularly easy.
What would be all the solutions
to Kirchhoff's current law,
A transpose w equals zero?
Every w now since I've
found the right number,
every w will be a
combination of those two.
Ah, well wait a minute.
Have I got them all?
I should have thought,
what about current
around the big loop?
That would certainly
satisfy Kirchhoff.
Plus one, one, so why is
this not number three?
Around the big loop
I have a one and then
a one on the fourth position.
Backwards on five,
backwards on two.
And so there is number--
So I'll put number three
with a question mark.
What's up with that guy?
You know, unless mathematics
has got to close up shop,
this better be a
combination of those.
And of course, it is.
If I send something around
the top loop and something
around the second loop
and add them together,
they'll cancel on
the middle edge
there and produce number three.
So this is probably
just the sum.
If I add that one to that one,
I think I get number three.
So number three is true.
It's a solution but
it's not a new one.
OK.
That was simple, right, once we
saw that loops gave the answer.
But, it's, actually
it's quite important
and appears everywhere.
In fact the theory of
electrical networks,
current laws and so on.
I mean that used to be
a, like, basic course
in electrical engineering.
There was a text by Professor
Ernst Guillemin, I remember.
It's sort of not so central
to the world any more.
And now-- Bu the structure
is just right somehow.
And what I wanted to say is
you could take, in those days
you maybe took loop
currents as the unknowns.
You could think of
currents in the loops
as your principal unknowns.
We don't do that now.
But, oh, there's, yeah
it comes up again.
Knowing all the solutions to
A transpose w equals zero,
well, you'll see, what's ahead?
It will be the continuous analog
of this, where I have flows,
not just around a
graph, but in a region.
And Laplace's equation
is going to come up,
and the equations of
divergence and gradient,
all that great stuff
is coming in Chapter 3.
And this is somehow
the discrete case.
These loop currents, that has
something to do with the curl.
And these differences
that A takes
has something to
do with gradients.
And this, Kirchhoff's
current law
has something to
do with divergence.
Can I just say ahead of time,
what we're doing is really
good to see and get it
because then you have a way
to understand vector calculus.
This is discrete vector
calculus we're doing.
OK.
Now, it's just right.
Forgive me for my sermon here.
Alright.
Now, may I bring the
pieces together finally?
May I bring the three
steps together into,
well first you would say
bring them into one equation.
Put the three steps, combine
the three steps into one.
OK.
So, what happens if I do that?
I take that last step A
transpose-- f is A transpose w.
So now I'm going to
get one equation.
Which is the
equation that's going
to have the stiffness matrix
in it, A transpose C A.
It's the conductance matrix.
And it's the equation
that a big finite element
code, a circuit simulation
code-- It's the matrix
they have to find and work with.
And those codes are enormous,
and SPICE by the way
is the sort of grandfather
of circuit simulation codes.
Somebody at Berkeley had
the sense to see hey,
we've got giant circuits now.
Modern circuits have
thousands of elements.
And you can't do it by eye the
way we can do this one by eye.
You've got to organize
it and write a code,
and SPICE is the start.
So one way to do it is to
end up with one equation.
So that was f equals
A transpose w.
I'm now going, I'm just
assembling the whole loop.
But w is Ce.
So that's A transpose
Ce, but e is b minus Au.
Nothing new there.
Nothing new maybe except that it
involves both the f and the b,
where our earlier
examples involved either
an f, in masses and springs,
or a b in the squares.
Now they're both here.
So now, that's my
equation, f equals this.
And now let me just move that to
the, let me just recollect it,
that's A transpose C A, the
big thing that I wanted to see.
I'll put it on the left side.
And what will I have
on the right side?
I'll have A transpose C b.
And I'll have, f is now
coming over to the other side
with a minus.
Minus f.
That's the big equation.
You could say that's
the fundamental equation
of equilibrium.
And you see how it's right?
It involves the A transpose
C A, which we expect.
Over here was the
A transpose C b.
Now, which problem,
before networks,
produced an A transpose
b or an A transpose C b?
That was least squares.
And now, so that's the
least squares, the b term.
The b is there with
a couple of matrices
because b entered the
problem just one step around.
It had two more steps to go.
It had a C step and then
an A transpose step.
Whereas f up here is
at the very end and now
it appears with a minus sign.
That's different from
springs and masses
simply because the sign
conventions, you could say.
OK, there is the equation.
OK, fine.
So that's what
you have to solve.
And actually I think of that
as the fundamental problem
of numerical analysis.
How to solve that equation.
More effort, more thinking
goes into that than probably
any other single problem.
In some form.
OK, and here's some
part of that thinking.
Part of that thinking, and
another important possibility,
is to keep-- This was like the
one equation, the one field
problem, this corresponds
to the displacement method.
Can I use words that I'm
not going to use seriously
for another few weeks?
This would correspond to
the displacement method
in finite elements.
In FEM, FEM for
finite element method.
That's the displacement
method, it's the method
that that most people use.
It's the standard method.
OK.
But it's not the
only possibility,
and let me show you a second
one that involves two equations.
Because that's also
very important,
with many other applications,
that we will see but
haven't seen yet.
So my two equations, I really
should say two systems,
because one equation, that's
a vector equation of course.
So I have a system of two
vector equations, that
would go into a block
matrix and you'll see it.
OK, so what what two
unknowns am I going to keep?
u, I'm keeping.
Displacement, I'm keeping.
But I'm also going
to keep what I
think of as the other
important unknown, w.
So the other important
unknown is w.
So now I have two
equations and one of them
is just that, is
just the current,
is just the current law, the
balance law A transpose w equal
f.
The only guy I'm
eliminating is e.
Initially you could say I've a
three field system. u, e and w.
Now, e and w are
so easily connected
that I'm going to eliminate
e. e is c inverse w.
I did it actually here.
This w is C(b-Au),
that's we know.
If I multiply by the C inverse,
then I have C inverse w is,
and I bring the Au over to the
far left and I have only the b
left.
Everybody saw that, I
did a C inverse there
to get e off by itself and
then I substituted for e,
I put in the u part
so e's now gone,
and the equation is C
inverse w plus Au equals b.
That's my two field system.
Now, there's a matrix here.
This is really nice.
I just want to write that.
I've got to what I want but
now I want to look at it.
So I think of a two by two
block matrix multiplying [w, u]
and giving me [b, f].
And I want to ask you
about that matrix.
So this is the matrix for
when I've only eliminated e
and I've still got
w as well as u.
OK, you can read off
what's in that matrix.
What goes up here?
C inverse, of course.
Positive diagonal, usually.
Easy.
What goes here is a rectangular,
that guy is rectangular.
A transpose is multiplying
w, so it goes down here,
and this equation
has no u in it.
That matrix is worth noticing.
And let's spend the rest of
this, the remaining minutes,
just to think about that matrix.
I just want to say,
what if I keep w and u,
this is an important
possibility.
And it's important in finite
elements which as you know
is just a terrific way to
solve a whole lot of continuum
problems.
And what's it called when
I have w and u together,
both unknowns, not
eliminating w now,
it's called the mixed method.
So this corresponds to the
mixed method in finite elements.
It corresponds to the
possibility of keeping w and u.
Well, and you might
say, wait, isn't there
a third possibility?
And what would that be?
Keep only w.
Here we kept only u,
here we've got them both,
this is kind of the mother
of all equilibrium equations.
And another possibly
would be to keep
only the w's, to make the
currents the primary unknowns.
And that, in the finite
element structural context,
that would be saying
make the stresses.
So of course it'd be
called the stress method.
It'd be called
the stress method,
and Professor Pian in
Course 16, now retired,
was one of the major developers
of the stress method.
The difficulty with
the stress method,
the reason it
didn't win big time,
is that the w's, if you make
them the unknowns you've got
a constraint on them,
Kirchhoff's-- Not all w's are
allowed.
Somehow over here
all u's are allowed,
and that made it much easier
to set up the problem.
So the displacement method
is the 95 percent winner.
But there are problems where
maybe C inverse is complicated,
or C is too
complicated and you're
better to-- We can see that.
That's later in the
book, but we want
to see now about that matrix.
Well, if I wrote
that matrix down,
and let me write just so
you-- I want to ask you
about that block matrix.
What's its size?
Now just focus entirely
on that block matrix,
because that's
what I care about.
What's the size of that matrix?
Let's see, what's the
size of C? m by m.
What's the size of A? n by n.
So what do I have here?
I've got n rows and
m plus n columns,
and there's n more rows.
It's of size m+n.
It's got the n
u's and the m w's.
Of course, m+n.
And the natural size, right.
So it's got more
unknowns but we'll
see, oh in
optimization you bring
in Lagrange multipliers, that's
just exactly parallel to what
we're doing here.
You have more, you have
extra bunch of unknowns.
That's what we have.
Now what else about that matrix?
I was going to write down
a very, very tiny model
for that matrix.
I'll just make it two by two.
Here's a model for that
matrix where C is just a one
and A is just a one.
I mean, it's kind
of laughable, right?
That model, this
is the real thing.
But it gives you an
example to check against.
OK, what's a property
of that matrix?
It's, again?
Symmetric.
Good.
That's a symmetric matrix.
Because what happens if I
transpose that block matrix?
That A block will flip
over here as A transpose,
the A transpose block
will flip up there
as A, what happens to
the C inverse block?
C is a symmetric guy.
In fact, it was just
diagonal in our imagination.
The key point is it's symmetric,
its inverse is symmetric,
its transpose is the same.
So that's a symmetric matrix.
That's a good thing, right?
Now we've got a matrix that's
symmetric, square symmetric.
OK, what's my other
question about that matrix?
Is it or is it not
positive definite, right?
We've got to answer
that question.
Have we got a positive
definite matrix?
Would all the
pivots be positive?
Would the eigenvalues
be positive?
What's your guess?
No.
That matrix is not positive.
No way that a matrix
with a zero there,
a zero block, or that
matrix with a zero number
could be positive definite.
No, no way.
The energy in this guy, this
u transpose Au, you remember,
would be u_1 squared
and u_1*u_2, twice.
And no u_2 squareds.
And that thing is
definitely indefinite.
Right?
In the u_1 direction
it looks good,
that's things positive there.
But if I took u_1 and u_2
to have opposite signs,
and made u_2 big
enough then of course
this just brings it down.
So the graph of that
would be a saddle point.
The graph of that
would be a saddle.
OK, and now here I have the
same thing on an m+n size.
So what do I have?
Actually, you could see.
The last exercise is mentally
do elimination on that matrix.
Mentally do elimination
on that matrix.
So start with the first m rows.
We'll work with those first.
What will elimination do,
what will the pivots be like,
what will happen at the
beginning of elimination?
When I start with this matrix?
Well it meets C inverse right
away, that diagonal matrix,
and it's extremely happy.
Those will be the pivots, right?
They're sitting
on the diagonals,
zero off the diagonals.
They'll be positive pivots, I'll
have m positive pivots here.
And then I get down to where
A comes in the picture.
So on the last board here,
let me just copy this matrix,
[C inverse, A; A transpose, 0].
An elimination is going to,
it'll be very happy with that.
But it's going to put, so
it's happy with that row.
Block row.
It's going to do an elimination
to get a bunch of zeroes there
and what did it do?
This was elimination,
this was subtracting,
yeah what did it subtract here?
It multiplied these
pivot rows by something
and subtracted from these lower
rows and got the zero block.
And what did it multiply by?
What do I multiply that
block row, and this
is a perfect, perfect exercise
to see how blocks are just
like numbers.
You can deal with them.
What do I multiply
that block row by
and subtract from the
row below to get a zero.
You said C A transpose, but
I don't think that's it.
A transpose C. You've got to
multiply by A transpose C.
First of all, C A transpose
wouldn't be a possibility.
Wrong shapes.
A transpose C is the four
by five, five by five guy.
So you multiply A transpose
C, that cancels that,
leaves the A transpose, when you
subtract it gives you a zero,
and what does it give you there?
What shows up there?
A transpose C multiplies
at A, subtracts
so it's actually what shows up
there is minus A transpose C
A. Let me write it in there.
Minus A transpose
C A. So that matrix
is exactly what
comes from this one.
It's exactly what we
do when we eliminate w.
That's what elimination is.
I just eliminated w by
getting a zero there.
And I got only an equation,
but notice the minus.
So, final question, what are
the signs of the last n pivots?
The first m were all positive,
and they were sitting
on the diagonal already.
The last n are not
so easy to see,
but we can see what
sign they have.
And what sign do the
last n pivots have?
Minus.
Because they come from
a negative definite.
Minus A transpose C
A is shown up there.
So that's the saddle point.
Saddle points are, when you
have two-field problems,
you're talking
about saddle points,
and the mixed method in finite
elements is exactly that.
And the tricky part is
then with the mixed method,
you're sort of not so
perfectly guaranteed
that the matrix is invertible.
Because we have plus
stuff and minus stuff.
OK, thank you, that's great.
And I'll see you Monday all
about the exam and review,
it's a great chance
to think back.